that you know that person you're
planning to become, your brain thinks
they're literally someone else.
Researchers discovered something that
explains everything about why you keep
letting yourself down. When you imagine
your future self, your brain activity
looks identical to when you think about
a complete stranger. Think about it. You
wouldn't stay up late if it made your
best friend exhausted tomorrow. But
future you, they can deal with it. This
is why your Monday motivation disappears
by Wednesday. Your brain is protecting
you from a stranger's workload. But
here's the hack. Write a letter from
your future self to current you. Have
conversations with future you. Suddenly,
future you isn't a stranger. They're
your mentor.